[Musique]
en
ils ont fait la une de l'actualité
les médias vaison starifié voir statufié
on ne parlait que d'eux on ne voyait
qu'eux et puis jour au lendemain ils ont
tout et l'éphémère panthéon de la loire
mais vers les projets de l'info ont
éclairé ailleurs république plus à
zapper aussi vite qu'ils avaient quittée
l'incognito elles sont retourné à
l'anonymat qui était-il d'où
venaient-ils pourquoi et comment
avait-il acquis leur célébrité de quelle
façon eux et leurs proches avait t-il
vécu leur d'état ria pour quelles
raisons qui existe avec grecque que
s'est il passé depuis bref que sont ils
devenus dont tout le monde apparaît à
travers d'abord des archives de la
gloire puis une enquête sur leur vie
aujourd'hui et enfin une interview
vérité je vais vous raconter leur
histoire voici tout le monde va parler
l'émission qui rallume
[Musique]
j'accueille minutes à fernandel
des taxis blancs des claquements de
portes hier
mélange de sentiments
malgré ma vie le prix que je paye ses
tongs aux quelque deux heures sans
sommeil pour souvenir de toi
pour elle est alléchant
station du métro sortie vers la patate
moyo
je suis
voit même que j'en fais trop une vraie
doublure dans un dé quoi
ma vie m'a dit tu peux me faire si tu
peux houllier
mon cheval inc ans
oh
[Musique]
tout le monde en a parlé a pris l'avion
direction l'espagne pour retrouver le
chanteur franco-espagnol nilda fernandez
dans les rues d'une ville chère à son
coeur madre je vous salue depuis ma
venue ici on dit magali madrid déjà ses
batteries de madrid pour moi au départ
parce que quand j'ai connu cette ville
j'ai fait une chanson derrière karzaï
chanson je me suis aperçu que les gens
qui ne connaissaient pas madrid pouvait
s'émouvoir à partir de textes qui
n'avait rien à voir avec eux mais qu'ils
avaient à voir avec un sentiment
est dans le coeur de la cité royale il a
bien sûr ces endroits favoris on va
rentrer dans un super magasin music
très beau
ce bel endroit c'était un éditeur il ya
des partitions ici de 1825 durée de 15
magasins de musique puis 19e siècle
[Musique]
faux
pour moi c'est important le rapport à
classement surtout que j'avais une
guitare comme ça et on me l'a volé donc
c'est une guitare espagnole mais plutôt
de flamenco ses buts aussi du terrain
l'a donc son des guitares voilà de base
que j'ai toujours acheté à barcelone que
ce qui m'arrive est débout et là j'en ai
plus il faut que j'en trouve une autre
quand il est de passage dans la capitale
espagnole nilda en profite pour revoir
des personnes qui compte pour lui
mais ça va maintenant
il retrouve ainsi un leader des indignés
qui s'opposent à la politique
d'austérité en espagne
bonjour je participe pas directement
avec alors mouvement parce que je suis
par ci par là c'est difficile mais en
tout cas si tu veux autour de moi et
dans mon métier je m'indigne en
permanence dire jusqu'à la radio ici
mars à madrid rio madrid et puis j'ai
balancé des trucs parce que j'en ai
profité parce que l'histoire direct que
dire des choses qui sont
son hétérodoxes quand ils sont pas
qu'ils se disent pas sont à bout et j'en
profite je pense qu'un artiste à la
libère pour aaron ses chansons révèlent
les angoisses les paradoxes des combats
d'une société espagnole dont il est
resté très proche et en hauteur engagé
il entend bien faire passer des messages
nilda doit maintenant aller répéter le
concert qu'il donnera ce soir mais avant
il fait un crochet par la télé espagnole
le temps d'une interview
comment je parle de tout
en en valais ag des balances c'est à
dire des problématisations il des
les essais de son à l'institut français
où je vais chanter ce soir
on ce poète au liban
et j'ai globe
youssoupha
[Musique]
quelques jours plus tard tout le monde
en a parlé retrouve nil d'art cette fois
à paris où il doit préparer un concert
sur une péniche amarrée sur la scène
alors là on va dans une somme de
péniches mais c'est quelque chose de
plus grand et voilà c'est là où je
devrais faire un concert de l'année
prochaine
moi je n'ai vu je trouve ici ce qui est
ce qui m'a plu ici on casas et c'est le
possibilité de faire autre chose que
simplement scène la scène publique
l'intérêt paris c'est tellement de choix
que tu peux choisir en fonction d'une
envie d'un plaisir d'une rencontre aussi
quoi c'est vachement bien et moi je me
prive pas de ça je fais pas une salle
parisienne pour faire une pâle au sein
parisienne parce que c'est souvent très
stressant mais justement cet endroit
c'est une amie qui nous a présenté myla
est intuitif il choisit les lieux de ses
concerts sur des coups de coeur quel que
soit l'endroit dans le monde
[Musique]
le prochain aura d'ailleurs lieu à
buenos aires
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
nilda fernandez hilda bienvenue sur le
plateau de tout le monde a parlé ouais
vous êtes né sous le prénom de daniel à
barcelone dans le quartier populaire de
sens le 27 octobre 1957 et 27,6 me date
de naissance officielle ouais en fait je
suis né deux jours avant le 25 j'avais
jamais de la famille un peu négligents
témoin inscrit le 29 on disons que
j'étais né le 27 en fait c'est compliqué
mais c'est pas très grave parce que vous
dit volontiers jeunes et chaque matin à
l'endroit où je me réveille
alors famille originaire d'andalousie
mais protestante ce qui est assez rare
en plein catalogne catholiques avaient
fait partie des premiers dégâts l'âge
après la nette de naissance voilà
deuxièmes décalage alors votre père
était sculpteur sur bois il encourage
votre intérêt pour la musique
d'ailleurs vous chantez à la paroisse
protestante de barcelone très jeune oui
oui parce que mes parents étaient des
joues très mélomane du peuple mais vous
paierez coûté la neuvième de beethoven
disent qu ils ont été très bien il avait
une très jolie voix ma mère aussi donc
ça fait partie de ces espèces de culture
populaire un peu raffiné quitté voilà
que j'aime l'aristocratie populaire vous
avez six ans lorsque votre famille fui
le franquisme
vous abandonnez votre enfance espagnol
et dites-vous l'amandier de mon
grand-père où je me perds chais pour
regarder la mer c'est une petite
bourgeoisie lui était coiffeur pour
dames et il avait fait construire une
villa et dans cette vie là il y avait
dit il dit
un jardin étage parce que c'est très bon
teigneux et voilà il y avait le monde y
est tout en haut moi je regardais là
alors en arrivant en france vos parents
décident que leur exil et définitif vous
êtes donc naturalisé français alors en
grandissant vous avez le sentiment que
vous serez musiciens comédiens passait
pas encore très clair dans votre esprit
la seule certitude que vous avez c'est
gousserey artistes et voyageurs oui
quand j'étais gamin à barcelone il y
avait celui qui conduisait le tramway et
il y avait le type derrière qui
vendaient des billets ouais et je voyais
qu'il avait une vie ils voyageaient de
sa journée il discute avec les gens et
gagner beaucoup d'argent parce que tout
le monde lui en donnait qui vendait les
tickets et quand j'étais gras je sais ce
que je devrais faire
à 15 ans vous commencé la guitare et le
solfège vous écrivait des chansons un
peu idéaliste un peu mystique vous dites
je croyais au salut puis j'ai eu
l'intuition qu'il faut vivre d'abord
devenir artiste trop vite c'était pour
moi
un peu inquiétant parce que
je pense je pensais qu'il fallait quand
même se confronter à des choses assez
realbasic
être parce qu'après j'avais l'intuition
qu'on partait dans une autre dans une
autre sphère et effectivement ça m'a
beaucoup aidé de ne pas me mettre dedans
la glace et puis chanter ça jamais été
mon truc
alors à l'adolescence d'étudier votre
langue natale à lyon et à barcelone
c'est là vous découvrez leur cas vous
êtes en ballon de lorca c'est linverse
de l'affairé vision j'ai retrouvé un
professeur qui m'avait initié à la
poésie à l'oeuvre de leur cas je les
retrouvais ya pas longtemps elle est
venue dans un concert c'est madame
saillard et effectivement j'ai fait des
études et même je continuais j'étais
donc déjà dans le métier de chanteur va
dire et je continue à étudier parce que
j'aimais bien cette cette confrontation
avec l'intelligence des autres et c'est
ce que je disais c'est le contraire de
télévision parfois
ensuite vous enseigner pendant un an
normandie et puis vous commencez à
voyager avec votre guitare dans un
circuit de petites salles de barde club
ça va durer dix ans alors il se passe
des trucs absolument
incroyable vous dit un soir à lille dans
un cabaret il y avait un paraplégique
qui disaient ses poèmes un berger
allemand qui hurlait une vraie cour des
miracles et j'ai fini par dormir dans la
cuisine
défini peur de rien dans la cuisine de
deux étudiants que j'avais rencontré
l'un
mais ça a été une prise de conscience
aussi parce que je pense que je voulais
aller le plus loin possible dans le dans
le simple le plus loin possible de
pommes confronté tout de suite à de
quelconques que
star académie de cette époque là celle
inverse un autre soir vous chantez dans
un repas spectacle les jambes ils ont
bouffé par le fort les tables sont à la
hauteur de la scène et là vous donnez un
coup de crédence une bouteille de rouge
beaujolais vert plein pot jeunes ils
veulent vous casser la gueule
parce que les là j'ai pris conscience
comme le coup si jean j'ai pris
conscience que c'était pas ma voix quoi
sauter dans ces conditions mais chanson
au plus plein mon orgueil souffrait trop
con pas se faire souffrir que vous êtes
comme ça je m'en sortirais pas quoi mais
en donnant ce que ce coup de pied
je n'ai je crois que donner un coup de
pied aussi ouais moi même courir non
c'est bien tu as compris pasqua après
ces années galère donc en 1981 vous fait
écouter une cassette c'est pathé marconi
à claude de jacques alors claude de
jacques c'est l'un des derniers grands
directeur artistique réussie de choses
dedans on croirait un homme qui qui
avait de l'intuition mon intuition
musicale artistique s'était confronté à
barbara loup garou enfin tous ces noms
et moi voilà il était avec qui je l'en
ai je n'ai enregistré en studio à côté
c'était un conte sèvres dans les studios
pathé marconi et moi aussi alors claude
se partage entre jon et moi et j'ai
beaucoup de reconnaissance pas c'est
beaucoup voilà vous fait un album mais
heureusement qu'ils ne connaît pas un
grand succès passe un peu inaperçu
ben oui je l'avais fait pour moi donc
c'est difficile j'avais fait pour moi
mais en 1987 au c'ur de l'hacienda vous
enregistrez madrid madrid en a gros
succès énorme succès qui sera repris
derrière par miguel bosser quatre ans
plus tard vous sortez votre deuxième
album qui s'appelle tout simplement
nilda fernandez et là vous chantez nos
fiançailles énorme tube à nouveau
oui c'est du chose inespérée inattendue
parce qu'en réalité ce sont des chansons
que j'avais faite sans penser du tout
qu'elle serait à ce point non écoutez
maintenant on dit nos fiançailles mais à
l'époque il y avait tout pour ne pas
passer à la radio et voulait pas que ce
soit le single d'ailleurs les gens de la
mer
quelque chose de plus qui montre juste
nous le dise ça parce que s'ils rentrent
avec cette chanson je rentre comme ça je
roule pas
vous êtes cinq fois nominé aux victoires
de la musique vous emportez une vous
fait la première partie de sting à bercy
devant 18000 personnes
oui mais c'était un choc une révélation
parce que j'ai fait 40 minutes de
musique avec des musiciens ce super bien
passé les gens étaient un peu surpris de
voir arriver un petit bain place d'un
grand blond mais bon ça s'est bien passé
et ce qu'il m'a dit c'est très musical à
la mais moi j'étais horrifiée par ce que
j'ai vécu j'ai vécu 18 mille personnes
derrière des barrières à cinq mètres et
je me suis dit toi tu si c'est ça le but
d'un métier de chanteur ou d'artistes
ces hausses pour voilà dix-huit mille
personnes entassées qui sont loin c'est
s'est passé pas de l'humain c'est la
méthanisation c'était aussi dur que la
bouteille de beaujolais sur la table du
spectacle vous va dire ouais mais bon je
les fais je fais jusqu'au bout avec 7
mais en sortant j'ai dit si c'est ça le
but de métier de facteur c'est pas mon
but en 1992 ça sera trois semaines au
théâtre de la renaissance et le grand
prix de l'académie charles cros qui
n'est pas rien c'est le concours du
disque on peut dire et là c'est la
célébrité quelles ont été les réactions
de vos parents à ce moment là
j'étais plus a vécu depuis un moment
alors je sais pas très bien je crois que
moi ce que je voulais qu'ils ressentent
je sais pas si ce qu'ils ont ressenti
mais je pense que oui quand même c'est
que ça justifie leur immigration ouais
c'est qu'ils se disent on a fait le bon
choix parce que souvent mon père m'a dit
oui qu'est ce que tu veux on est venu
hier pression qui nous dira si n'est en
fait c'est lui qui le dira s'il est
beaucoup beaucoup moins beaucoup plus
que nous et moi je lui disais nous l'ont
tu vois tu as bien fait de partir ce
pays parce que la france nous a offert à
l'époque surtout une autre ouverture
d'esprit quelles ont été vos rapports
avec les médias à l'époque
très bien se situe très bien j'avais
plus de problème avec les gens qui
étaient avec moi qui me disait des
conneries du genre mais sourit ah oui
oui c'est fabien s'annonce sur les
ouvriers vous disiez non s'il se sent
pas je vais sourire
vais gagner de l'argent oui bien sûr le
regarder je les ai beaucoup dépensé en
fait c'était pour moi une forme de
libération pour pour le dépenser dans
mon métier j'ai pas acheté deux maisons
j'ai fui tous ces pièges la deux mais je
suis parti en argentine j'ai emmené mes
musiciens j'ai chanté dans des pays
étrangers et ça aussi cross en fait que
je gagnais de l'argent et l'amour alors
est ce que cette célébrité vous a
rapporté des conquêtes ils n'ont pas une
fois que les cinq pompiers certainement
mais bon c'est pas en reste ambigu c'est
le plus bel homme du monde ce qui est
faux en fait il ya une forme de
challenge devant un chanteur quelqu'un
de connu qui qui m'a jamais vraiment
intéressé j'ai eu des belles histoires
des gens qui des personnes des femmes
qui ont vraiment été pour moi très
importante et puis voilà les histoires
n'ont pas continué mais ça n'empêche que
c'était bon c'est pas le grand amour
c'est grand amour pendant un temps
des grandes amours successifs quel a été
le meilleur moment de cette époque c'est
une tournée roulotte que j'ai fait que
j'avais décidé de faire sortir d'une
opération de la jambe je voulais plus
faire de concert ça m'intéressait plus
je trouvais ça assez
triste l'aigle et il est tourné parce qu
on vous sort de la boîte vous chantez en
vous remets dans la boîte de chanter il
ya un régisseur qui s'occupe de tout en
fêtant pour vous un fota disent
simplement gars là est donc la tournée
en roulotte gelé décidé en sortant de
cette opération 10 ans maintenant je
veux me que c'est comme une sorte de de
réhabilitation du métier le pire moment
de sa fait peur
disons que les mauvais moments les
difficultés c'était comment continuer à
être ce que je suis ouais artistes dans
un métier qui ne veut pas tout à fait
que tu savais comme patron 10 miles ou
10 et une île date est une star tu peux
pas prendre le métro oui et moi je lui
répondais tu sais pourquoi tu me dis
cela ne fait pas dire son prénom et nom
je dis pas parce que tu veux me
contrôler ouais prenons le métro je t
shirt voilà vous avez toujours été un
électron libre un sérieux les tronches
je sais pas anatole
alors vous dit en fait
tu entres en concurrence avec tes succès
donc avec toi même après il faut des
galets et c'est angoissant en fait
quelqu'un a dit il faut pas faire un
deuxième film il faut tout de suite
passer au troisième oui donc c'est vrai
qu'on rentre en concurrence avec ce
qu'on a ouais et moi je les résolue
d'une manière assez brutale quoi c'est à
dire j'ai fait le contraire ouais
j'avais passé neuf mois faire un disque
est dans un endroit très clos à
l'hacienda et là j'ai passé trois mois
faire un disque où je rentrais je
sortais du studio il était montmartre à
500 mètres de chez moi je recevais mes
amis ça énervait beaucoup de l'ingénieur
du son je partais retourné je revenais
donc j'ai fait le contraire en 1993 vous
fait la promo de l'adaptation notre
album en espagnol
et là vous voyagez les usa le mexique le
chili l'argentine c'est le début en fait
d'un long voyage qui finira jamais
aussi le début des des amarres larguées
je crois qu'ils étaient vraiment quelque
chose de très prémédité c'était quelque
chose que je voulais en fait vous
refusez de capitaliser oui parce que ça
l'est tout comme moi qu'on emmène rien
de ce monde et je pense que c'est très
dur de mourir avec des biens très très
dur c'est horrible alors ce voyage vous
emmènera à moscou vous avez passé cinq
ans à moscou et vous produisez le
dernier concert de claude nougaro là bas
vous passez des moments rares avec lui
ça fait partie des choses qui sont des
cadeaux de la vie parce qu'on s'y
retrouver avec claude quatre jours
c'était l'hiver lui chanter dans une
salle qui s'appelle la philharmonie qui
est vraiment une très très grosse salle
de 1500 places mais personne ne le
connaissait mais qu'on avait fait ce
qu'il fallait pour que les gens viennent
et lui il était
très malade déjà puisque c'est son
dernier concert il était et on se
promenait bras dessus bras dessous je
crois que son épouse a gardé des images
de ce film va vous dites à côté des
russes les producteurs français sont des
anges chez nous il ya encore des
scrupules là bas les choses se règlent
la kalachnikov vous souvenez de
négociations musclées avec des bonds du
tchétchène dans les bureaux d'un casino
moscovite quoi c'est chaud ils voulaient
pas me payer ouais et donc il a fallu
que je discute avec les grands gorrite
ça et dans ces cas-là ce qu'il faut
faire toujours c'est donner l'impression
surtout là-bas qu'on a une protection et
leur mode cloud donc en étant arrogant
je suis arrivé
j'ai mis les pieds sur le bureau on est
en argot ils ont un doute ils se disent
c'est pour protéger frais au moins
poutine qui est derrière ce qui est tu
fous mais ils l'ont cru alors vous irez
en ukraine en biélorussie dans les pays
baltes au turkménistan en israël à cuba
enfin vous êtes un vrai globe trotter
musiciens et voyageur finalement c'était
beau prémonition d'enfants c'est ça que
je voulais faire ça que je voulais faire
et je fais qui m'enchante qui en réalité
je veux je veux mourir un jour avec des
souvenirs ouais c'est pas avec des
regrets
alors vous êtes nostalgique aujourd'hui
de l'époque de madrid madrid de nos
fiançailles nous nous le sommes parce
que quand on me disait une chose
horrible on disait prendre mais prend
prend tous les bons les bonne sorcière
carabosse prend proche mais qu'est ce
que je vais prendre pas moi tu sais pas
dans combien ça va durer et moi je leur
répondais de manière très prétentieuse
surtees pour la vie et en même temps que
je le disais je veux des main
afin de le prouver mais au moins je le
disais il fait de dire ça te coupent les
ponts et c'est ça brille c'est le show
si c'était à refaire votre ville d'à
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil
c'est une question que je me pose pas
vraiment parce que nous la question
apparaît
sans réponse j'aime bien les questions
avec des réponses puisque on ne revient
pas en arrière tout ce que j'ai fait
c'est bien même mes erreurs tous
regrettent rien le jour vous allez
mourir qu'elle se voulait qu'on écrit
sur votre tombe
moi j'ai vu mourir mon père ya pas très
longtemps au mois de juin j'ai eu la
chance il m'a offert cette présence de
moi à son chevet je suis arrivée du
paraguay d'argentine juste à temps je
suis arrivé aux 48 heures le passé
ensemble j'ai vu mon père partir et
franchement on s'est regardé dans les
yeux je vais parler ce qui parlait plus
et quand il est parti quant à lui son
dernier ce qu'on dit son dernier soupir
c'est vraiment ça j'ai vraiment eu
l'impression qu'il n'était plus là et
effectivement dans une autre dimension
mais j'ai une conviction arrêté plus là
après le cimetière sommes pas vraiment
ému donc moi je pense que je ne pense
pas du tout à ce que je vais écrire
parce que c'est pas je serai pas là donc
c'est même pas la peine de monter vers
furieux je veux pas être quelque part
pour occuper de l'espace il faut que je
serai en train de tourner au sein des
étoiles ou d'être incinéré
j'ai eu d'autres rêvent plus plus plus
fou plus poétique de mourir en marche au
et qu'un cheval tombé sur le chemin ils
s étaient là
merci j'étais très heureux de rallumer à
s'ouvrir
[Musique]
j'accueille patrice drevet
salut à tous c'est nouveau ça vient de
sortir le mini journal est un journal
pour les jeunes et les ados c'est la
volonté de vous donner tout simplement
une info plus décontractée un nouveau
rendez vous sur tf1 un peu avant 18
heures les lundis mardis jeudis et
vendredis 10 minutes d'actualité en
trois parties l'info du jour plus un
mini dossier sur un événement
particulier
et enfin tout tout tout ce qui vous
intéresse des fringues à la bande
dessinée en passant par le rock n roll
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
patrice drevet à pézenas dans l'hérault
où il est conseiller municipal pour un
réveil dans les airs
maria
on va aller au club de ma libre on l'a
survolée seat 500 m d'ici et
il ya des vignes et c'est parti pour une
journée bien chargée enfin s'ils sont
authentiques quatre caves de bien
démarrer du premier coup
alors stéphane fait environ et il ya 34
ans il est venu me voir en disant est ce
qu'on peut faire un vin qu'on
appellerait la cuvée drevet ben c'est ce
qu'on a fait puis alors ça marche bien
c'est un très beau vin je me trompe pas
williams a débuté
à l'eau
et là il me répond aux vins oui d'abord
mais voir celui là on a déjà vu celui en
avion qui était magnifique et je suis là
et pas mal aussi regarder
et oui les miracles de la météo et
merveilles toujours patrice est
d'ailleurs le monsieur météo à ses
informateurs pour prévoir le temps réel
sur les grenouilles
oui oui
quel temps il fera demain
bon bah il va pleuvoir et il commence sa
tournée quotidienne par des artisans de
la région patrice est très engagé
politiquement et tient donc à les saluer
l'ouvragé
d'écart au ciment que son grand-père
fabriqués qui l'a remis
au goût du jour
[Musique]
hu
donc en fait tu le mets comme ça et puis
c'est bien ça
regarde ma première tesselles
pas mal ça lui david
toujours fidèles arrivés au marché il
est très
près
du bourg il va bien de chez nous on va
très populaire bah ça va très très bien
comment tu vas alors votre maison de
paille toi oui oui c'est bien aussi
ouais impeccable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mètres de saucisses au piment
d'espelette ou pour demain soir on la
fera cris en avant de la servir à
et au détour d'une ruelle il a même des
supporters
je suis belle et météorologique pour cet
après-midi
on attend quelques gouttes cet après
midi d'été
[Applaudissements]
allez un peu de sérieux il est temps
d'aller travailler direction l'hôtel de
ville pour une réunion municipale
salle à l'abri et on va pouvoir faire
notre petite conférence
[Musique]
tous les deux après jean-pierre latina
on s'est pas trompé parce que j'ai
regardé qu'est ce qui est urgent à faire
le plus urgent
[Musique]
voilà signer des mariages finir
voir ma fille au revoir
c'est ça le rythme de ces journées
alliés loisirs et travaille toujours
avec humour et sourire
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
patrice drevet patrice bienvenue sur
plateau tout le monde a parlé merci
alors vous êtes né le 4 janvier
1948 à paris dans le 14e à 4 heures du
matin alors on note tout de suite une
sur représentation du chiffre 4 et ça
s'est pas arrêté ici vous avez fait
votre fameux mini journal en 1984 vous
avez travaillé 44 ans dans l'audiovisuel
une histoire formidable c'est un jour
vous dites j'ai joué le 4 aux courses
dans la quatrième il est arrivé j'ai
joué quatre millions sur le 4e but
alors qu'on fonce sans terre vous dit
papa du livre côté de maman les heures
nécessaires à ma conception enfance
fauché mais heureuse du côté de
saint-ouen du côté du marché aux puces
votre mère se bat pour élever ses trois
enfants vous et pivote demi-frère et
votre demi soeur voilà leurs fins de
mois c'est difficile quand même hein ah
ben je suis allé chez le crémier puis
c'était plus facile si c'est moi qui
allait acheter le lait et le sucre et
que je disais j'étais pas plus haut que
trois pommes maman pas sera payé en fin
de mois alors vous dites à saint-ouen il
y avait les cocos à la mairie il est
curé à l'église et comme c'est le curé
qu'il a trouvé le premier appartement de
ma mère demandait ben voila je me suis
retrouvé au patronage tout à fait c'est
vrai et quelque part je suis très
contente de ça parce que pas mal de mes
copains qui étaient du côté des cocos à
la mairie ont pas tourné comme moi n'ont
pas mal tourné mais disons que ça fait
mal comme j'avais pas de père à la
maison il y avait une ourse un curé qui
faisait 2 mètres de haut et quand je
faisais une connerie ben je prenais un
coup de pied au derrière voilà j'en
faisais par deux alors enfant de choeur
communion solennelle et scout et scouts
de vous laisser votre promesse de scouts
à lourdes
un événement pour vous qui vous a marqué
à jamais en fait assez fascinant parce
qu'on remonte le calvaire de nuit aux
flambeaux étape par étape
c'est resté gravé gravé dans ma mémoire
alors à l'école cette bonne élève mais
assez petit train oui je te veux
m'occuper de l'animation
alors vous retrouver dans un pensionnat
de père paul b oui c'était comme un oui
sous comme un polonais je suis témoin ah
oui je suis témoin mais on était
tranquille comme ça le soir au dortoir
complètement cela dit j'en garde un
souvenir extraordinaire c'est un prof de
latin qui m'a donné l'envi 2d mais le
français est de jouer avec les mots et
ça je les gardais tout toute ma carrière
alors finalement vous retrouver à
l'école du spectacle rue du cardinal
lemoine vous rencontrez d'ailleurs
patrick dewaere qui est là-bas en même
temps que vous vous appreniez quoi alors
on apprenait soi-disant la culture
générale pendant quatre heures
l'après-midi et le matin on pouvait
vaquer aux répétitions on pouvait le
soir joué dans des pièces de théâtre et
moi je faisais de la musique à l'époque
je tapais sur une sur une batterie
j'avais un groupe de rock qui s'appelait
les les oui sont passés dans les fêtes
foraines donc soir je finissais à la
batterie alors fin 1964 encore 1,4 comme
un cap vous avez 16 ans il vous devenez
assistant de pierre laforest sur une
nouvelle chaîne qui s'appelle la
deuxième chaîne de télévision vous
l'avez connu comme ambiance foraine tout
simplement parce qu'il est bien recruter
des figurants à l'école du spectacle
j'ai été désigné et puis je suis passé
dans la première émission alors j'étais
fasciné j'ai demandé l'autorisation de
revenir la semaine d'après pour le
prochain enregistrement
il bondit ok pour voir toi comme ça que
j'ai tapé l'incrusté quand il y avait
une bière à aller chercher on me on me
donnait un peu de monnaie et pis j'y
allais et puis après je suis monté en
grade j'avais le droit aller chercher
les sandwichs et ça s'est terminé par le
fait que j'organisais les auditions de
serge lama de françois zahoui et vous
finissez responsable d'édition du 20
heures quand murray est avec roger
gicquel donc j'étais le patron en régie
quand on était trop long c'est moi qui
prenaient l'initiative de supprimer un
sujet où l'autre au téléphone avec avec
le présentateur bien évidemment alors
une chanson culte comme beaucoup de vos
collègues vous êtes mis à l'écart de la
télévision et vous vous retrouvez
serveurs dans les voitures restaurants
des wagons lits oui bah oui fallait
et dans une voiture et ce temps c'est
pour mieux
en garde ça aussi un souvenir j'ai fait
des films après dans ces voitures j'ai
réalisé des documentaires c'est la belle
époque c'étaient les voitures bleues
tous montés frey et il y avait des
clients assez riche d'ailleurs qui
choisissent l horaire de leur train en
fonction du nom du chef de cuisine dans
l'orient express à face était le la
compagnie internationale des wagons-lits
vous retournez ensuite travaillé à la
télévision de 1969 jusqu'en 84 vous
réalisez dans le monde entier des
interviews de stars pour le journal
télévisé alors j'étais au service
culture de la rédaction de tf1 alors que
ça ouvre les portes j'ai lié d amitié
avec la femme de marley qui m'appelait
pour ja il a photographié à central park
à new york par un truc de ouf alors
bowie mccartney mick jagger et yoko ono
franck france a pas dans les toilettes
qui l'aimé pas bien les journalistes en
fait pour me venger je dis ça serait
marrant de confesse une interviewe dans
les toilettes avec le look et tout ça je
lis interviewé dans les toilettes de
chez plus quelle grande salle en 13 et
mercury qui m'a draguée à mais bon
les jazz cluny c'est pas mal ça alors je
le dis parce que l'un à côté de l'autre
qui en est
qui est ce qu'un faussaire de l'autre
alors printemps 1984 encore 1,4
évidemment vous présentez presse-citron
week est un magazine pour ados et là
antoine de caunes vous propose de venir
le rejoindre sur canal+ mais vous
préférez faire le mini journal le fameux
mini journal tous les jours sur tf1 à 18
antoine m'appelle en me disant tu vas
voir on va s'éclater la nouvelle chaîne
on va être on va faire ce qu'on veut
c'est extraordinaire je suis dit oui je
viens et je vais voir mon directeur de
l'information du 10 janvier là il me
regarde droit dans les yeux et me dit
non c'est le dixième à partir c'est par
été le meilleur mais il faut que pat
augmenté mais qu'est-ce que je peux
faire 20 tu rêves je dis bah il ya une
petite tranche de 10 minutes qui
appartient à l'information personne ne
s'en sert moi je j'aimerais bien il ya
du dessin animé tu me la donne et je
fais un petit journal télévisé décalé il
est court on l'appelle le mini journal
et là il s'est passé un truc fou c'est
que les adolescents ont regardé le
journal c'est à dire quoi je pensais pas
le faire pour les jeunes ce sont eux qui
se sont approprié le mini journal
c'était quand même regarder à 50% par
des adultes
alors le samedi avec minimag aussi qu'à
une mission culte
de l'époque alors une anecdote que
j'adore c'est un jour donc il n'y a pas
d'oreillettes le sujet n'est pas prêt et
le réalisateur vous dit le sujet pas
prêt rajoute quelques phrases de temps
que ça arrive comme il me dit ça en
direct au téléphone je dis oui maman oui
maman excuse moi maman oui bien sûr on
va en parler mais excuse moi maman parce
que là je suis en train de travailler je
suis en direct je te rappelle plus tard
un moment sans voir je t'embrasse et je
raccroche 1 et le lendemain des tas de
messages de gens puissent et un fils
formidable en plein de travail vous
répondez à votre maman c'est vrai que
c'était ya eu un retour fabuleux et b
beaucoup de courriers non vraiment alors
à l'époque on veut très très star
évidemment quelles ont été les réactions
de votre entourage ma mère elle et elle
était fière voile en parler partout son
fils à la télé votre père biologique n'a
pas cherché à vous retrouver un train
qui sait même pas qu'il m'a fabriqué
d'accord puis quand les gens dans la rue
me disent vous en avez pas marre qu'on
vous reconnaisse dans la rue moi je
réponds toujours vous savez moi mon père
m'a pas reconnu à la marée haute le
reconnaissent ça me fait vraiment
plaisir fou vos relations avec les
médias à l'époque c'était quoi alors il
y avait deux choses j'étais le chouchou
parce que c'est un peu l'émission que
tous les journalistes rêvé de faire je
faisais tout ce que je voulais je voyais
mon directeur de l'information deux fois
par an et deuxième chose très importante
pour moi c'est que j'étais un petit peu
le l'école du journalisme de télévision
beaucoup de jeunes sont passés par mini
journal pourquoi parce que quand il
allait voir le directeur de
l'information il disait pas fait des
essais fait donc un reportage pour le
mini jeu on a eu
plein de journalistes qui ont pour la
plupart réussi et qui sont passés par
l'école mini journal et ça j'en suis
très fier alors vous avez gagné de
l'argent à l'époque non c'était
mini-journal mini salaires c'est là où
je me suis fait un petit peu
mais c'est pas grave sur le plan
amoureux ça vous a apporté de nombreuses
conquêtes
non mais j'ai toujours pensé que c'était
pas c'était pas ça c'est pas parce que
tu es connu que tu fais plus de
conquêtes qu'un autre jeu élevé mais ça
a été quand même un assuré le minimum
syndical
c'était quoi le meilleur moment de cette
époque
c'était d'aider des petits moments comme
ça où je recevais james blonde sur mon
plateau qui venaient s'asseoir à ma
place et mini journal des trucs comme ça
c'était c'était facile en moins
fascinant le pire moment
le pire moment
ou tu vas pleurer dans l'est dans les
toilettes c'est quand tu apprends compte
à supprimer l'émission parce que tu un
bétonneur qu'arrive qui sait pas trop ce
que c'est que la tvh un avion et voilà
je me suis un tout petit peu vengé au
moment du 7 d'or j'ai fait balancer une
dernière justement en octobre 1987 vous
recevez un 7 d'or pour le mini journal
et le minimag du mag et le problème
c'est qu'en fait vous venez de
démissionner un mois plus tôt et je
balance je tiens à remercier le
président stéphan tout
jeudi l'ancien parce que nouveau c'est
lui tout à remercier la mais pourquoi
ils ont viré cette émission mais parce
qu'ils ont mis un feuilleton américain
la place qui coûtait 10 fois moins cher
ça coûte cher un journal télévisé c'est
un vrai journal télévisé pour les jeunes
là vous partiez de téléphone et sur l'a3
fait génies en herbe ensuite sur la deux
et en 1996 on vous confie la météo ce
qui me plaisait c'est qu'on m'attendait
pas là non à vous dit que c'est plus
difficile de faire la météo en direct
que d'interviewer david bowie à broadway
se dit même plus que ça je dis que c'est
plus difficile que de présenter journal
de 20 heures quand vous êtes en direct
avec william leymergie adèle et de latin
que vous avez prévu trois minutes de
bulletins qui vous dit à coco en étant
tahri torres 20 secondes mais claudie 10
secondes avant quelques bulletins en
plus à la gestuelle parce que derrière
tawila rien en fait j'ai un fond
d'ailleurs il ya un fond vert ou à fond
bleu et puis tu as le retour nous dans
le retour tu es à l'envers tant que ça
part dans tous les sens et il faut pas
trop se mettre devant la température de
la corse s'agit pas de faire rigoler
pita les bretons au site ou dépasse un
peu j'ai fait ça quand même temps la
météo 11 ans quand il est parti
je suis parti en 2008 ça faisait
longtemps que je faisais la météo
n'avait jamais fait aussi longtemps
quelque chose en télé alors
le maire de pézenas me dit patrice tu
veux pas venir sur ma liste et comme
j'avais organisé un festival de films
sur les métiers à pézenas qui marchait
très bien j'avais été un petit peu à
deux parties voilà je suis parti là-bas
je suis parti et je me suis arrêté à
france 2 fin janvier début février je
partais en campagne électorale pour la
mairie aux dernières élections et fait
quatre ans car en tout cas c'était aux
régionales
évidemment si je fais le pari dacca ont
qu à dire être obligatoirement
81 ans + 6 6 1 6 4
mais je descends dans un parking et
reste une place et celle à 40 et quelque
chose
est ce que vous êtes nostalgique de
l'époque du non je suis pas nostalgique
mais je m'interdis d'être nostalgique
j'aime bien jouer les anciens
combattants quand je revois les copains
et la jungle et comment on a pu faire un
bien évidemment je suis pas nostalgique
si c'était à refaire votre vie qu'est-ce
que vous ne referiez pas pareil patrice
alors je ne cesserai pas les cours
d'anglais ah oui parce que interviewé
david bowie à broadway
en ayant un anglais approximatif je me
débrouillais dans la ville je me
débrouille mais après quand ça rentre
dans le technique et heureusement david
bowie avait à l'époque une costumière
belge qui était donc trilinguisme et qui
a servi un petit peu sur des moments
difficiles mais quand je lui dis ma
dernière question je dis à david bowie
comme ça are you the last rockstar là il
me regarda qu'un grand sur la région sur
la toile
il serait alors le jeu vous allez mourir
que sous les coups marquent sur leur
tombe
suivez la flèche
merci patrice est très heureux de
rallumer la lumière
[Musique]
m
j'accueille catherine trautmann
[Musique]
retour sur le bateau france 2000 en
compagnie de catherine trautmann qui
restez avec nous merci tout à l'heure
sur france 2 il ya le val de vienne qui
est traditionnel alors nous on va faire
notre taux bas là nous voulait pas
comment y danser tous les deux on peut
essayer
on
se tire
oui
r ma face à l'as clermont reste un grand
moment
des médecins
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
catherine trautmann journée marathon
dans l'est de la france où il évolua à
strasbourg et pour commencer la journée
une étape nostalgie à la bibliothèque de
l'université
ici nous arrivons dans la bibliothèque
de théologie de l'université de
strasbourg c'est un dieu pour moi qui a
beaucoup marqué mes études mon
expérience de jeunes chercheurs c'est
pour ça que c'était un petit peu un
petit peu ma maison je j'arrive à
retrouver quelques heures
et revu les ouvrages qui ont marqué il
ya presque trente ans ma la formation
universitaire une seconde maison où elle
aime revenir feuilleter les revues les
ouvrages portant sur le protestantisme
la place des femmes dans la société et
dans l'art
et si cela
est justement avant d'aller travailler
catherine s'offre un instant de culture
[Musique]
elle passe visiter une expo sur l'art de
la récupération de récup'art fait ça
c'est le hasard d'objets qui trouve tout
à coup une forme et une façon de faire
sourire de revenir en quelque sorte dans
l'environnement dans la vie de manière
détournée
batteries rechargées elle peut commencer
sa journée de femme politique
maintenant on va à ma permanence
parlementaire vice présidente de la
communauté urbaine de strasbourg elles
passent chaque semaine à sa permanence
pour faire le point et donner des
instructions à son équipe je suis avec
mes collaboratrices dans ma permanence
parlementaire le lundi matin c'est le
dépouillement du travail du week end
commun ou m'a demandé des arbitrages et
nous retrouvons pour échanger débriefer
débriefer
l'occasion aussi de revoir le planning
de sa semaine souvent extrêmement chargé
mon agenda est certainement un art très
compliqué
il s'est en fait c'est un peu aussi la
difficulté de travailler sur plusieurs
lieux
strasbourg bruxelles paris je travaille
tous les jours toute la journée une
grande partie des soirées samedi et
dimanche compris j'ai juste les jours
qui sont vides avec les vacances mais ça
remonte à voile après c'est clair merci
on s'appelle absolument
merci beaucoup je
pars à un séminaire confidentielles sur
la situation économique et puis ensuite
on se retrouvera au parlement européen
c'est donc dans l'après-midi qu'on la
retrouve cette fois dans son rôle de
députée européenne présidente de la
délégation socialiste française
nous sommes ici au parlement européen de
strasbourg et c'est l'endroit où une
fois par mois le parlement se réunit
pour voter sur les textes législatifs
qu'il examine une journée ou une journée
devant d'agenda et est toujours très
diversifiés l'insi sportif je peux dire
que c'est même par moments athlétique
mais ça fait partie du jeu
voilà maintenant je vais rejoindre ma
réunion de délégation je continue mon
programme
la journée fine pour noms parfois
celle qui a occupé depuis trente ans de
nombreux postes de la politique
française n'est pas prêt de raccrocher
les gants
deux cents
[Musique]
ça
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
catherine trautmann catherine bienvenue
sur le plateau de tout le monde a parlé
merci alors vous êtes né le 15 janvier
1951 strasbourg sous le nom de catherine
argens grand père pasteur
grand mère fille de pasteur père colonel
d'artillerie votre mère se destine à une
carrière de chanteuse lyrique elle n'a
pas exercé et votre père lui militaires
avaient été envoyées en allemagne dans
l'armée d'occupation après la deuxième
guerre mondiale et il vous fait
comprendre très jeunes l'importance de
la réconciliation
soit par la persuasion dire qu'ils vous
emmener à 9 ans au camp de concentration
du struthof
soit pas raclée c'est à dire que quand
vous appelez les allemands les
russe le scénar la clé vous avez été
formé dans ce milieu à la fois très
rigoriste évidemment pasteur fils de
castle temps est à la fois par l'europe
autre père qui ne voulait plus entendre
parler de la guerre est ce que mon père
m'a appris c'est que la guerre n'est pas
une fatalité et qu'en temps de paix on
fait tout pour empêcher le conflit ouais
et ce qui m'a intéressé dans la
politique c'est peut-être l'art de
dénouer préalablement
l'émergence d'un conflit alors votre
père reçoit l'ordre de partir en algérie
vous avez mal vécu c'est cette
convocation à faire la guerre de votre
peur j'ai eu très peur mais comme comme
un enfant à naître de voir son père
risquer de mourir ouais donc quand mon
père partait après une permission est
retourné en algérie pour moi je savais
que peut-être je ne le reverrai pas donc
j'ai été très tôt confronté au risque
est confrontée au risque de marins
alors votre scolarité s'effectue au
lycée d'état de jeunes filles de
strasbourg êtes passionné de philosophie
vous tournez même vers la théologie et
en 1968 avant le bac vous dit la société
est contestée de toutes parts mais
personne ne se pose la question du
fondement de la société c'est-à-dire
notre héritage judéo-chrétien
l'éducation que j'ai reçue et une
éducation à la responsabilité
personnelle
la responsabilité personnelle et
emporter comme l'exercice de sa propre
liberté donc je choisis pour moi même
pour ma réflexion
parce que je suis né dans un contexte où
la religion avait une place particulière
je choisis de faire des études de
théologie mais c'était aussi la période
de la théologie d'abord de dieu c'est la
période où de grands théologiens parle
justement de l'abandon de toutes valeurs
religieuses en cas de conflit et au fond
je me demande comme femme aussi si la
religion n'a pas au fond créé justifier
les inégalités entre les hommes et les
femmes c'est là qu'on retrouve le
féminisme ferait alors ensuite vous
orienter vers l'histoire des religions
comment les autres religions répondent à
la question de dieu oui dans toute
civilisation et là je parle pas de la
guerre des civilisations
il y a un besoin au fond humain de
traiter la question du dépassement la
question de la transcendance et ce
rapport à l'absence rapport à la mort ce
rapport à l'au delà ou à l'inexplicable
à l'innommable c'est au fond une
question qui peut être traitée par
l'animisme par d'autres traditions et
j'ai donc c'est l'époque on est tous des
lecteurs de lévi strauss on a des débats
absolument énorme sur la psychanalyse je
lis fera évidemment pour comprendre au
fond l'inconscient et en quoi cet
inconscient est liée au phénomène
religieux et donc au fond pour moi c'est
d'abord du tout simplement pour ma
propre mon propre plaisir et le défi
intellectuel que je m'étais donné je
voulais être prof de russe en fait oui
alors l'époque strasbourg est un lieu
d'ébullition intellectuelle vous lisez
ces airs vous lisez fans où vous vous
intéressez à la psychanalyse
situationnisme au structuralisme et à la
théologie de la libération
développé en amérique du sud oui c'est
en fait ce que j'ai découvert dans mes
études à l'école enfin au lycée parce
que j'avais des professeurs de français
qui nous ouvrons notre intelligence
notre notre raisonnement sur la réalité
du monde c'est en préparant un exposé
sur aimé césaire que j'ai découvert cet
auteur et j'ai découvert le mouvement de
la négritude et bien sûr j'ai lu fanon
parce que fanon c'est au fond celui qui
a théorisé
cette le colonialisme et cette situation
et pour moi c'était la suite de cette
question de l'algérie de l'indépendance
de l'algérie c'était au fond comment est
ce qu'on peut trouver une issue
responsable au colonialisme et aux
inégalités du monde en fait à 19 ans en
1972 épousé jacques trautmann petit fils
de pasteur on reste quand même non et en
ce début des années 70 le loup baba cool
à vous habiller chez des soldeurs pour
fabriquer des bijoux que vous vendez oui
aux festivaliers d'avignon sur la place
de lâcher oui c'est ça ce type ba ba oui
j'étais baba j'ai appris à filer la
laine j'ai appris à l'atteindre g oui
bien sûr c'est c'était un mode d'être
c'était une façon à la fois avec peu de
moyens de se débrouiller c'était une
façon de choisir un mode de vie qui
était très ouvert aux copains
c'était une style de vie mais je précise
sans produits
associés alors
non mais c'est vrai qu'à à l'époque les
gens pensaient que c'était une vraie
solution kwassa apparaissait comme
quelque chose comme un futur possible
j'ai un cousin qui a carrément créé une
communauté
qui a été un écologiste radical avant
l'heure j'ai des amis qui ont rejoint
des communautés moi j'ai et j'ai eu
cette phase baba cool mais j'en suis
sorti aussi parce que à un moment où ça
ne permet pas complètement d'avancé et
où il faut peut-être passer à des choses
plus militante et plus en plus engagée
alors sur le plan politique après avoir
côtoyé d'assez loin les mouvements
contestataires de l'époque vous
détournez rapidement du marxisme au
profit du pragmatisme rocardien g20
colleter à la réalité en fait oui en
fait ce qui m'intéresse c'est ça
m'intéresse toujours c'est comment
transformer de manière
disons à distance à moyen terme la
situation sociale que dans laquelle nous
sommes et qui pose problème mais comment
aussi la transformer immédiatement on
pouvoir jouer deux des moyens qu'on peut
avoir donc le pouvoir est un moyen
d'action et c'est la raison pour
laquelle que ce soit par rapport à la
cause des femmes que ce soit par rapport
aux changements dans ma vie locale j'ai
estimé que je devais devenir une
militante politique voilà alors avec une
poignée de putschiste rocard tiens vous
plonger sans état d'âme dans le marigot
et vous allez faire votre chemin vous
voilà devenu femme politique voilà oui
c'est en fait c'est une succession de
hasards de chance une opportunité dire
que je choisis ou contre andy de masse
le courant de michel rocard et donc
comme je suis récente que je j'arrive
dans une section où il ya des conflits
on prend la dernière arrivée on se dit
celle ci va pas nous gêner on va la
prendre et on va on va la rendre
responsable de notre section comme ça
que j'ai commencé parce que je me
trouvais laraque y avait un conflit et
qu'on a dit par la prenons la femme qui
vient d'arriver en 1983 est élue
conseillère municipale de strasbourg en
1986 député du bas rhin en 1989 maire de
strasbourg je faisais de la première
femme à être élue maire d'une ville de
plus de 100000 habitants oui c'est
d'ailleurs une expérience solide de ma
vie politique d'abord j'ai connu la
période qu'on peut appeler des quotas à
ce moment là certains ont parfaitement
acceptée
que je sois parmi les élus d'autres
dévaloriser le fait que les femmes
soient interdits mais protégé et qu'elle
soit l'objet d'une discrimination
positive en 1986 j'ai été candidat sur
une liste en deuxième position parce
qu'aucun homme ne voulait cette place
puisqu'elle était reppert réputé perdu
j'ai donc fait double campagne j'ai fait
la campagne de la liste et j'ai fait une
campagne de femmes et j'avais comme
slogan une femme député e avec un petit
peu pour l'alsace et c'était une c'était
une vraie double campagne et j'ai passé
et après j'ai entendu ceux qui ne
voulaient pas de cette place se dire
j'aurais été encore mieux éduqué je vais
axer sur voilà donc 89 maire de
strasbourg 95 allez vous faire connaître
sur la scène nationale en organisant la
fameuse manifestation dite du sursaut
républicain donc ces quatre-vingt mille
personnes contre rassemblement du front
national c'est une de mes expériences
c'est plus difficile parce qu'à tout
moment cette manifestation pouvait
déraper et c'est en même temps un
souvenir très important vous devenez
nationalement célèbre le pen vous
appelle catherine la rouge et ensuite
ils se baladent sur les scènes ses
meetings avec une effigie de vous en
carton qu'il fait huer parfait militant
seimat hat qui a été offerte à une forme
de délire violent qui que j'ai
d'ailleurs
contesté devant le tribunal et il existe
aujourd'hui à un jugement qui stipule
que la violence même sous forme
symbolique est condamnable en 1997 je
sais pas vous nomme porte parole du
gouvernement et ministre de la culture
et de la communication là vous avez
vraiment une politique médiatique
quelles ont été les réactions de votre
votre entourage votre mari par exemple
quand il vous a vu devenir
ministre et je pense que pour ma famille
tout a changé quand je suis devenu quand
je suis devenu maire ouais parce qu'en
même temps françois mitterrand avait
décidé que je devais être parlement
européen notamment pour défendre le
siège de strasbourg et donc les présence
absence la complexité d'une organisation
de l'éducation de nos deux filles avec
mon mari qui était un peu père mère il
faut le dire est une très forte
mobilisation de la page avec le rythme
n'a pas changé la ville principale était
paris mais je continuais quand même de
travailler aussi pour strasbourg
c'est autre chose par contre d'être dans
le milieu parisien est d'être à la fois
comme ministre de la culture
normalement libre de parole et même
provocante le même par moment disons
détonnant pendant le concert
gouvernementale et la gt parte parole
donc il y avait quand même en période de
cohabitation une certaine contradiction
c'est la raison pour laquelle je ne
pouvais pas à terme garder c'est cette
double responsabilité et je devais
retrouver ma liberté alors avec les
médias ça s'est plutôt bien passé non
j'ai vécu à la fois
l'attention
la couverture médiatique est ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui le bashing au moment
où j'ai des difficultés sur la réforme
de l'audiovisuel public privé et où je
travaille sur une loi qui est très
combattue par par la droite et qui est
très politisée dans le débat j'ai cette
difficulté de conduire ce projet
notamment de réduction de la publicité
entre autres et à ce moment là je vis ce
que vit chaque politique lorsqu'il
commence à vaciller un peu je regrette
de ne pas avoir eu la chance d'aller
jusqu'au bout j'aurais pu montrer que
malgré cela on pouvait on pouvait finir
et l'emporter
quel meilleur souvenir de cette époque
c'est incontestablement
la possibilité de travailler avec des
personnalités très différentes j'ai
circulé partout dans les petits théâtres
de province j'étais à la comédie
française je pouvais voir au fond cette
floraison de création française c'est ça
qui pour moi a été un enrichissement
extraordinaire et un plaisir absolu et
le pire souvenir c'est certainement
d'avoir été confronté à une
incompréhension notamment des milieux du
théâtre lorsque j'ai voulu promouvoir la
charte de service public qui est
aujourd'hui la référence est donc depuis
cette époque qui est revendiquée comme
devant rester en quelques sortes et
inamovible et qui à l'époque a été
combattu ce qui va politiquement
fragilisée or quand vous avez été nommé
ministre vous avez renoncé à votre
mandat de maire une fois que vous êtes
plus ministre vous retourne évidemment à
strasbourg mais là une liste
indépendante menée par jean-claude
petitdemange divise par deux les voix de
la gauche ce qui fait que l'ump edf
l'emportent moi j'étais votre second
s'était elle vous appelle vous remplace
au poste de meneur juan et quand vous
revenez dit je reste et quand je vous
dis je me présente aussi vous faites de
liste il ya une liste dissidente roland
ries ce qui est maire aujourd'hui a
rejoint la liste mais je pense qu'en
politique et c'est normal la division
est sanctionné là vous découvrez la
trahison vous relisez shakespeare racine
vous dit tout ça est vieux comme le
monde oui ça fait partie de la politique
ne pouvoir attire pour ma part je n'y
étais pas préparé parce que pour moi le
pouvoir est transitoire c'est vous et
confiez vous n'êtes jamais propriétaire
et vous devez le rendre et donc c'est le
pouvoir d'agir ce n'est pas le pouvoir
de représentation je n'ai jamais vécu le
pouvoir de cette façon et donc c'est à
la fois contrariant par rapport à ma
conception du pouvoir et c'est en même
temps aussi et ben nul puisque
finalement organisé
la perte d'une élection c'est
particulièrement
particulièrement bête et méchant
aujourd'hui vous êtes nostalgique de
l'époque vous étiez ministre non je n'ai
aucune nostalgie pour une époque si
c'était à refaire catherine qu'est-ce
que vous ne referiez pas pareil je pense
que je prendrai plus de temps qu'on
voyage est pour pour pouvoir aussi me
ressourcer et peut-être expliquer ce que
je n'ai pas fait un moment donné qui
auraient été nécessaires pour que les
gens comprennent un j'en étais
je vous allez mourir sous les coups
marquent sur votre tombe soyez passant
c'est bon ses traits à vos draps lumière
sur vos catherine merci beaucoup
[Musique]
jacques rousseau ainsi qu'aux
il ya un gros nez des moustaches et des
lunettes il est tout à fait magnifique
c'est un des deux plus grands animateurs
du monde il s'appelle chico d'agneau il
a aussi un gros nez des moustaches des
lunettes j'ai nommé l'autre animateur
magnifique gros show business et nous
sommes là tous les samedis soir sur
antenne 2 pour vous présenter la plus
grande émission du monde rock'n'roll
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
alexandre marcellin alias gros show chez
lui dans le 16e arrondissement de paris
[Musique]
et
toujours très actif il prépare la
programmation musicale d'émissions de
télé mais n'en oublie pas moins sa
chienne fidèles comme une ombre c'est du
bon du bon jambon
alléger voilà après ça
on va aller travailler mes chiens
beaucoup plus important même que le
travail est beaucoup plus urgents ma
chienne est formidable parce qu'elle est
un peu sourde mais elle adore la musique
elle sans les vibrations et elle adore
le cinéma également est étonnamment je
les emmener voir autant en emporte le
vent il n'y a pas très longtemps et elle
n'a pas du tout aimé le film et j'ai été
très surpris parce qu'elle avait adoré
le livre donc voilà brouchaud n'a
décidément pas perdu son humour
légendaire
la preuve dans l'émission il tient une
chronique matinale le chien de mon père
pu énormément du derrière quand il lui
arrive de péter et oui et je sais que
c'est souvent
la vie est dure le
[Musique]
monde en a parlé a aussi retrouvé son
complice sam chouikha alias chico lors
de sa tournée matinale des commerçants
du 7e arrondissement de paris pour aller
chercher son pain ils bénéficient d'un
accès privé à la boulangerie melo c'est
sam
bons joueurs mais ça va bien
c'est un beau petit campagne via cutoff
ouais comme thème voilà là c'est parfait
bah je connaissais sa voix je
connaissais un petit peu sa gueule
attends je connais son caractère
bon je ne brûle pas je te remercie
t'envoyer à très bientôt
allez vous emmène ses journées chico les
consacre à sa fille et à ses proches
mais lui qui est resté un grand enfant
ne manque jamais une occasion de jouer
au kiel je tiens juste à dire que c'est
marc qui a fait ça de ces petites mains
tout le décor tout ça et je trouve ça
assez extraordinaire alors voilà quand
on appuie
droite ce qui fait au niveau de
l'échelle
régulièrement il me bat voilà mais c'est
le plaisir c'est vraiment du plaisir
vraiment un jeu d'enfant réalisé par une
vente personnes-là
gros choix aussi aiment passer du temps
avec ses amis
son hobby c'est la pétanque bon c'est
bon
c'est leur hockey j'arrive
tuer la salle on voulait café est ce que
tu as les boules ben évidemment et une
fois parti ça aide en bas de la maison
on joue alors normalement on est plus
nombreux aujourd'hui on est deux donc
c'est quand même des moments très très
important si tu veux venir avec moi
qu'il est gentil mais ils trichent
dietrich non c'est trop court
essayez de t'entraîner tout va essayer
de libérer tombant
ah voilà c'est bien la bougie bras
gauche
cette instance est obligé de jouer à
gauche moi tu en voilà regarde à ya
hélas y arrive à faire là
pendant ce temps là chico se rend chez
le coiffeur le même depuis vingt ans et
la même coupe très original 27 ans 17
coups
j'ai essayé pourtant délaissé poussé
pour les avoir comme toi ouais mais bon
c'est pas évident tu vois tu t'en la
soie banon tu sais pourquoi en fait j'ai
compris pourquoi ouais parce qu'elle
change avec la couleur de mes cheveux
qui blanchissent confiant mesure au fur
à mesure c'est les défis différents
bah ouais c'est vachement bien public
journée les lunettes c'est pas en fin de
journée le duo se reforme pour quelques
heures enfin si chic on va bien arriver
enfin j'attends gros comme d'hab ça fait
20 ans que j'attends ce genre labour des
années des années j'ai toujours attendu
à la radio à la télé à la bourre voix te
voilà non mais tu as vu leur marché et
leur
voiture à coups de toit allait enfin
avoir un tout allait redonner un coup
toujours complices les deux systèmes se
retrouver autour d'un verre
la retrouver l'internet spectre
jouer on est d'une sobriété absolue
ouais mais c'est leur fils et leur qui
fait ça l'un pialat avec l'âge avec
l'âge on renverse
à l'époque ya 40 ans ont renversé mois
avec l'âge aujourd'hui on renverse
qu'ils pouvaient jolie et s'il ya bien
une chose dont il ne se lasse pas c'est
de se remémorer les moments forts de
leur carrière c'est qu'on est quand même
le je crois les deux seuls mecs au monde
à être partie à la frontière irakienne
et arabie saoudite pour remonter le
moral des troupes quelques semaines
avant la guerre du golfe
avant que chacun ne retourne à sa vie
d'aujourd'hui corps est selon moi
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
rousseau et shiko shiko
shiko bienvenue sur le plateau de tout
le monde apparaissent à les jours alors
on va commencer avec vous shiko shiko
d'agneau oui vous êtes bien sous le nom
de sam chouikha oui le 24 septembre 1947
au caire c'est exact air grossistes en
matériel de petite papeterie les crayons
les gommes et bim et mère femme au foyer
absolument alors très jeune vous
découvrez la musique en écoutant la
radio et en 1955 quand vous entendez les
premiers rock vous voulez immédiatement
une guitare que j'ai eue alors dans la
famille on parle français vous
fréquentez le lycée français du caire
mais on parle également arabe anglais et
ladino oui en ladino c'est une langue
judéo espagnol est utilisé notamment en
turquie exactement vous savez encore
parler de l'avion si l'open aux cimes
problème à à oui c'est un peu comme
l'espagnol quand même c'est de
l'espagnol c'est de respecter les niches
espagnol as
alors connaissance des langues sera
utile à tous quand après l'arrivée au
pouvoir de nasser vous déciderez de
quitter l'egypte et en 1957 vous les dix
ans vos parents renoncent à nationalité
égyptienne et de pouvoir partir en
france et là vous arrivez vous êtes à
patrick
petite carte
deux séjours sur laquelle je découvre
que je n'ai pas de nationalité et
marquer nationalité sans
alors votre père réussit à trouver une
place de grossistes en matériel de
bureau oui il finira par acheter la
boîte quand exactement absolument mais
c'était son métier déjà et en l'egypte
donc le refaire ici ce produit se pense
que ça a été plus facile alors à
l'époque évidemment vos parents n'ont
pas d'argent au départ ils sont obligés
de vivre à l'hôtel et votre frère et
vous vous êtes inscrit dans une pension
juive et c'est un déchirement parce
qu'évidemment s'est séparé jamais quitté
les parents de notre vie d'un seul coup
du jour au lendemain on les voit plus
que deux fois par mois alors ensuite la
famille s'installe à boulogne
billancourt vous passez votre enfant
sans l'agrément on est loin des bords du
nil qua non et les bords de seine
alors heureusement sakété la famille
part en vacances à nice oui et c'est là
qu'avec votre argent de poche vous
achetez chez ben qu'est devenu un
artiste mondialement connue évidemment
vous achetez vos premiers disques
exactement rue ton duty de l'escarène
exactement alors à la même époque à
l'olympia vous voyez les shadows oui
avec leurs fans de chanson attaches
absolument voilà vous faites un groupe
jouer dans l'est dans les rallyes dans
les surboums la pression après le bac
vous faites lesca quitte une école de
commerce que l'âge de 20 ans et là bon
vous en avais un peu marre de 2,2 du
côté strict de la vie les études c'est
oui ça va ça va 5 minutes puis moi
j'avais la musique en tête mon père
avait le commerce en tête et moi ça ne
collait pas vraiment fissiles alors
c'est arlette tabarre oui fameuse barre
l'assistante de lucien morisse directeur
artistique d'europe numéro un qui vous
remarque un jour où vous accompagner un
copain pour une audition aux disques az
exactement et vous aussi vous passer une
audition c'est à dire que j'étais sur
place je me suis dans le fond je trouve
que c'était bizarre ces auditions qu'il
y avait des jeunes qui ressemble à
claude françois qui venait chanter du
club françois des jeunes qui ressemble à
mireille mathieu qui chantait du
mireille mathieu le copain de sa
compagne et lui bon il avait ses propres
chansons puis moi je déconne et
j'adorais chanter en anglais et ses
éditions dans le fond est ce que puisque
je suis là ce que je peux passer
l'audition
alors un jour elle vous rappelle et elle
vous demande de présenter le zico rama
spécial jimi hendrix en direct à
l'olympia en entrant ainsi c'est quand
même arrête ta bar aba wee cc c'est
d'abord un c'est une femme qui est très
impressionnante et elle m'avait dit toi
tu as un potentiel qui aiment le rock tu
va présenter hendrix l olympia je me
suis retrouvé en octobre 67 à le faire
alors dans la salle il y avait votre
père votre grand-mère en fait mais ça
c'est un souvenir on était là je peux me
vanter de dire que je suis le seul au
monde à avoir vu son père né en égypte
ma mère n'est en état grand mère née en
turquie à istanbul qui venaient voir non
pas dans la rue
parce que jimi hendrix à devait les
affoler ah ben moi je ne comprenais pas
parce que dans la salle c'était velvet n
satine et elle passe mal shiloh mais moi
je voyais mon père si je peux me
permettre après le spectacle mon père
est venu me voir
et m'a vraiment posé la question mais je
voudrais te demander quelque chose toi
tu as été formidable mais ce garçon y
gagne vraiment de la journée en jouant
de la guitare comme avec son sort
réservé aux usa voilà la question alors
voilà le problème c'est que vous ne
rappelait pas barrette tabarre et là
votre père vous pousse à entrer chez
olivetti oui ouais c'est un peu plus dur
vous retrouvez à vendre des machines à
écrire des machines à calculer et riz
pour la plus grande satisfaction de mon
père le plus beau métier du monde
représentant oui et là vous en
échapperez pour travailler dans
l'industrie phonographique aurait fait
plein de trucs en fait cet auteur
compositeur attaché de presse directeur
de maison du chanteur qui s'appelle
alors ça va exact par sam chez az
évidemment directeur artistique enfin
voilà et vous décidez de quitter le show
biz après tout ça je décide d'arrêter
parce que ça fait très longtemps
beaucoup d'années c'est un métier qui
est très difficile très stressant
contrairement à ce que les gens veulent
y croire la gaillette ça s'entretient et
j'en ai marre donc je décide d'arrêter
et là vous faites de la pub des voix
dans la pub alors tout va bien et c'est
là que vous retombez sur alexandre que
vous aviez connu dix ans obama oui tout
à fait je sors d'un studio pub comme on
disait à l'époque à europe 1
et qui je rencontre cet énergumène qui
lui même était alors pas gros show
business voilà alias alexandre marcellin
dont vous êtes né le 12 novembre 1951 à
paris 9ème vos parents travaillent dans
l'immobilier est un petit commerçant
d'abord oui et il nous fait le chemin et
ça marche plus il passe à l'immobilier
voilà parce qu'il n'y a pas de stock
et oui alors vous passez votre enfance
entre paris et deauville oui parce que
ma grand-mère une boutique à deauville
donc je vais me la mets mai à deauville
tous les week-ends et les grandes
vacances alors va te souviens d'enfance
le plus marquant c'est le premier thé
pas l'âge de 7 ans quoi ouais alors là
par hasard ce que j'avais été malade
j'avais été un nom couché mathis
particulière et j'ai découvert à cette
époque là la radio et on m'a offert mon
premier thé pas et j'ai commencé à
acheter des disques et je suis tombé
raide dingue de 5,0 canal rock'n'roll et
le twist et la variété celle avec
l'autre françois et tout ce qui va avec
car à partir de là pendant vos études au
lycée condorcet d'être passionné de
musique de radio enfin vous n'êtes pas
en fait globalement je pense qu'à ça
globalement je pense qu'à ça je suis un
élève excessivement moyens et avec les
potes on n'a qu'une idée en tête c'est
lé à la gare saint lazare au magasin le
discobole pour écouter ou sur les champs
elysées tce symphonia bien sûr pour
parler véritablement écouter les
nouveautés parce qu'elle passait par la
radio allez acheter les imports tout
l'argent de poche passe là-dedans
passion absolue et partagent avec les
potes tiens tu connais ça tiens tu
connais ça on échange ça on écoute sa
passion complète et alors les études
passent très très loin derrière alors à
l'époque voulait pas devenir animateur
en fait vous êtes programmateur et
réalisateur animateur jamais c'est
arrivé tard par accident moi mon truc
c'est de rentrer dans une radio europe 1
clairement et pour faire quoi je sais
pas jeudi pour choisir les disques moi
c'était mon truc je savais pas que sa
simple et programmateur à nabeul et
c'est en 1971 que pierre delanoë qui est
alors le patron d'europe 1 vous découvre
alors que vous faites le dj à l'origine
à deauville et oui parce que quand
j'avais 18 ans j'arrivais que avec tous
les potes et on allait en boîte et on
trouvait le disque est absolument à
chier de l'époque j'imagine on a été
voir je sais plus qui lé directeur du
casino à l'époque on lui disant votre
disquaire il est vraiment à chier le mec
lui dit vous pourriez faire mieux et
s'est dit bien sûr très prétentieux et
je suis arrivé le week-end suivant avec
mes valeurs de disques et pendant je
crois une saison d'hiver et d'été aux
brumes elle est ensuite dans une autre
boîte aux galápagos j'ai fait ce qu'on
appelait disquaires et ce qui était
formidable parce que d'abord on passait
la musique on voulait pour faire tomber
les gonzesses c'était quand même un très
très grand bonheur et on était les rois
du monde puis un soir est un mec qui
vient de voir je faisais des études à
l'époque dentaires ce qui m'intéressait
pas un quart de seconde et ce type me
dit c'est vachement bien ce que vous
passez et il me dit c'est étonnant vous
voulez faire quoi dans la vie vous fait
que je lui dit en rigolant je dis moi je
rêve de faire de la radio je rêve de
rentrer en europe 1 je sais pas qui
c'était et le mec me dis bah écoutez je
vous laisse ma carte et c'est moi votre
téléphone voilà je m'appelle pierre
delanoë je suis directeur des programmes
d'europe 1 huit jours après il a
téléphoné chez moi mes parents et je
suis rentré europe 1 en 71 19 ans conte
de fées total alors après un stage de
programmation avec babar et un ratage de
réalisation sur campus l'émission de
michel lancelot je me suis mis à
travailler avec les gens qui étaient
complètement mes idoles commun avec
lancelot et bayal il y en a eu un paquet
parce que pendant dix ans vous allez
réaliser une rémission chez europe 1 et
jean loup la faune et on a monté mosic
avec jal un sosie qu'il ya eu christian
mora gildas jouffa pierre péchin voilà
coluche du monde ensuite vous fondez
radio bleue ça c'est la première radio
c'est en 80 à la demande de jacqueline
baudrier ça a été la première radio
seigneur ensuite radio capitale la radio
de perdriel pierre d'une nouvelle 81
80 une date importante puisqu'il ya le
monopole la radio créée tombe et là il
pas au lit on monte notre première radio
fm voilà et c'est à ce moment là que
vont retomber voilà sur sa manne arrivé
voilà leur jeu sony au pub on y arrive
oui voilà et alors je monte cette radio
et je suis un mec sérieux je suis un mec
patron de radio avec la cravate et
autres et je cherche des animateurs et
je me souviens d'une espèce de dario
moreno que j'avais connu dans les années
70 qui arrivait de chez barclay que des
disques sous les bras on était devenus
très très potes tous les deux on aller
bouffer dans les restaurants casher et
yiddish tous les deux mariés à se
raconter des bêtises et à se partager à
la même musique on est des malades
mentaux de musique et je choisis ce mec
là il est drôle c'est mon copain il
connaît la musique ça va faire un
formidable animateur de radio je
l'appelle je lui fais pas ci un casting
à toi et à laurent boyer
catastrophe les deux le truc c'est que
moi habitués à travailler avec les états
unis et ont fait beaucoup de voyages aux
états unis à l'époque pour moi la ffmc
représentait le bonjour avec une grosse
voix on est sur l'autoroute et c est
limité à judy gross comme très je les
engage pas ni l'un ni l'autre la
différence c'est que tous les deux vous
continuez à vous voir quand même sur en
dehors du boulot dix ans et quand vous
quittez capital pour créer 95 2 avec
robert namias là vous faites une
émission tous les deux en fait il n'ya
pas de pognon dimanche or savez pas quoi
faire accident de parcours voilà une
animatrice qui prend des vacances
personne a remplacé namias me dit tu te
démerdes on n'a plus de budget j'appelle
sam et je lui ai dit écoute j'ai jamais
parlé moi dans un micro de ma vie c'est
pas mon truc 3 non plus non mais on va
faire comme à la maison c'est à dire tu
vas venir été dit je vais prendre les
miens et puis on va sortir un tu te
souviens de sa écoute ça écoute ça et je
lui ai dit j a juste un truc on risque
d'être tellement mauvais moi je suis un
mec un peu connue maintenant dans ce
métier un peu sérieux et où je peux pas
faire ça sous mon nom on va prendre des
sur donc voilà ça comme il ressemble à
groucho oui gros show business moi vu
mon physique j'ai dit chico le contraire
et radio d'agneau et là vous faites le
légendaire montparnasse graffiti quoi
qui était moi je me souviens à l'époque
non absolument culte la gloire ça sera
la télé avec le top 50 et rock'n'roll
graffiti en ouverture des enfants du
rock oui absolument et ça ça a été pour
nous quelque chose de totalement
inattendu c'est que on tourne les les
émissions des requins de graffitis on
les tourne au mois de juin moi je pars
en vacances je vais en grèce 15 juillet
je suis sur le port je prends mon petit
café ma chemise hawaïenne je suis
tranquille etc et je vois les touristes
qui arrivent et qui n'arrête pas de me
regarder et moi je ne comprenais juste
pas ce qui se passait c'est comme ça que
j'ai compris que l'émission avait
cartonné ouais en fait et c'est vraiment
en voyant les gens c'est comme ça vous
arrive c'est alors qu'elle a été la
réaction de votre entourage votre père
par exemple à ce moment là à mon père
lui pour lui ça a été fin d'un seul coup
il avait oublié son commerce avait
oublié qu'il fallait que je rentre dans
son commerce et des rats mais tu
formidable vraiment je t'adore quand je
te vois à la télé c est la télé associe
deux parties ces voiliers parler comme
ça avec s'enrichir c'est quand on disait
qu'il avait l'accent de dalida y trouver
qu'il n'avait pas laissé
et en fait la télévision je tiens
aujourd'hui à lui à lui rendre vraiment
grâce parce que c'est vrai que on oublie
tout simplement que nos parents nous
regardent et donc on est avec eux
finalement je lui tenais compagnie et
voilà je ne saurai jamais trop remercier
terrain il était ravi ravi ma part en
moi pareil alors nous on a le même
parcours moi je suis petit-fils
d'ashkenazi arrivée de l'immigration
pologne début du siècle quand un jour
ils m'ont vu à la télévision faire le
clown parce qu'on vivrait on faisait
vraiment clown il aurait pu trouver ça
ridicule un visa d'or et ça ils étaient
de fierté absolue dites moi à l'époque
the young d'argent et tout ça non non
c'était pas gagné leur vie oui on va
dire ça comme ça mais on a gagné notre
vie parce qu'à l'époque n'avait pas les
producteurs indépendants on était là on
était vachement bien payés parce qu'il
faisait de la radio plus de là
plus de la télé plus un peu de pub plus
des détenus ont gagné très bien notre
vie de l'argent non non l'élégant 16 on
était vachement sérieux et oui moi je
j'ai épousé mon animatrice à l'époque à
rien j'ai engagé cricri à 95,2 ouais
épouse et donc moi je bouge pas une
oreille oui je sais pas t'imagines
aurait-il bouger une oreille maintenant
je pouvais pas bouger les domaines ont
été aujourd'hui une chose c'est que je
suis un fidèle un mâle ans avant tout
fidèle à main c'est vrai c'est jamais vu
bouger une oreille et n'a jamais fait
bouger une oreille non mais toi j'ai
connu beaucoup de choses ouais mais
c'est un petit matin tu as connu tout
mais marié injuste oui mais oui mesdames
la première erreur de jeunesse la
deuxième erreur tout court est la
troisième la bord du lac
quel a été le meilleur moment de toute
cette époque
le moment le plus magique quoi
alors moi très honnêtement c'est la
naissance de 95 2 way puisqu'on a eu
avec namias la chance d'avoir à partir
de 80 2 les moyens de nos ambitions à
savoir il fallait pas le dire à l'époque
mais c'était europe 1 qui nous finance
est en sous marin on avait des studios
somptueux et on avait surtout la
possibilité de payer nos animateurs donc
on a réuni autour de nos une dream team
incroyable de gens qui aujourd'hui
n'existe dans cette profession qui sont
laurent boyer qui est il n'a guy thierry
beccaro et là de retrouver mon pote pour
ses émissions qu'on faisait qui était
rock'n'roll graffiti moi c'était ma
récré parce que j'étais en fait patron
de la radio et tout d'un coup je mettais
ma casquette elle gus et j'allais faire
le con avec lui à l'antenne et vous
savez c'était quoi elle ne monte plus
magique de l'époque je crois que c'est
vraiment le premier soir quand on aller
au resto et qu'on entendait des gens dit
on a été écouté les deux cons
il a moi ça m'a recycle a été très
agréablement le pire moment de cette
époque alexandre la mort michel lancelot
puisque en 80 quand on l'a monté 95,2
etc namias on a en a réengagé michel
lancelot qui était plus du tout du tout
dans l'actualité et c'est quelqu'un qui
pour nous avait vachement content et on
était persuadé qu'il avait encore des
trucs à dire depuis un an après un soir
on m'a passé un petit coup de téléphone
on m'a dit voilà michel vient de mourir
il était au parc des princes il a
engueulé larbitre sur un match de foot
il a eu une crise cardiaque ça ça a été
un truc très dur et le lendemain matin
c'était un samedi bon bah on a fait
notre émission en direct qui a été une
émission en hommage à michel et ça a été
un bon moment mais abonnement voilà le
propos durs un brin firme heymans était
celui là oui by alors en 1991 alexandre
décidé d aviva serre chevalier et c'est
la fin du duo qu'est ce qui vous a pris
j'en ai marre 1 j'en avais marre et je
n'avais pas envie à cette époque-là de
devenir un animateur de télévision un
peu ringard qui cherchent du travail
nous marie france brière nous avait viré
de la télé un an avant on l'avait quand
même mal pris et je si j'ai plus envie
de tout ça j'ai plus envie et j'ai envie
de vivre autre chose autrement ailleurs
avec ma petite femme on est partis
effectivement on s'est pris une année
sabbatique qui a duré dix ans à
serre-chevalier il voulait partir de
voulait partir et quand est ce qu'on
peut faire on peut rien faire mais moi
je me suis retrouvée à la fois divorcée
orphelins moins quelques points voilà
c'est un peu le problème est nostalgique
aujourd'hui de l'époque non
nostalgie des souvenirs formidables 094
j attends que d'être est de très très
bons retours nostalgie moi je sais pas
ce que c'est alors ça mais si c'était à
refaire votre vie qu'est ce que vous me
referiez pas pareil bon je vais leur
dire ce ne serait pas vraiment une
erreur c'est je ne dirais pas mes
parents que je présente jimi hendrix à
l'olympia pour ne pas les voir arriver
parce que ça m'a foutu leur traque de m
et vous l'erreur la vraie il y en a une
qui est très très très grave je peux
l'avouer maintenant
quand on voit les photos on se rend
compte c'est la barbe entre 18 et 24 ans
j'ai eu le barbe maxime le forestier
avec les cheveux john lennon et les
petites lunettes alors j'ai raser ma
barbe compte sur lennon a rasé la sienne
évidemment et j'ai gardé la moustache
mais clairement si il y avait un truc à
faire ou à ne pas faire surtout c'est la
barbe si on voit les photos c'est pour
quand vous allez mourir que je voulais
qu'on remarque sur leurs tombes
tant va la cruche à l'eau qui est à
l'appareil
alors moi j'aurais pas de tombe moi
j'aurais pas de tombe il faudra
disperser les cendres à deauville à là
où je vais à la pêche c'est à dire tout
au bout de l'acheter voilà il faudra
disperser les cendres là il y aura rien
de marquer et si quelqu'un veut me faire
une petite visite ça sera là bas voyez
garçon s'est fait très heureuse
merci merci
c'était tout le monde en a parlé amis du
parking bonsoir
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu
de bleu